Welcome back to human emotion.
Um,
today we're going to discuss the continuing question of individual differences
in emotion.
Today we're going to focus on gender here.
I want to ask the question with you and have you think through our men and women
really that different emotionally.
So do they experience entirely different emotional worlds?
Indeed our men and women from different,
you know,
emotional planets.
Um,
how is it possible that we could see such great differences between men and
women emotionally given that for the most part we're all made up of the same
kind of genetic stuff or material.
So again,
our men and women really that different when it comes to emotion.
Conventional wisdom seems to suggest that men and women are different and that
women must be somehow more emotional and men.
And we see characatures of this in the news and even comics.
So I mean,
what you're seeing here is just this kind of depiction over and over again of
women being really hyper emotional and men being sort of relatively emotionally
sedated.
So how true are these kind of,
you know,
characatures and this conventional wisdom where we talk about men and women
really being these different emotional beings.
Um,
and this is what I want to talk with you about today.
So here,
let's answer the question together.
Our men and women really from different emotional planets.
We're going to go through the roadmap today.
First walking through this socialization of emotion from an early age,
some experimental findings,
looking at emotion between men and women,
and wrap up with takeaway questions and our expert interview.
So let's start with the socialization of emotion.
So this here is the idea that our emotions get socialized in us from a very
early age through culture.
So it teaches us sort of what emotions are appropriate to experience,
um,
and sort of what context they're appropriate to express.
And so to what extent might gender differences in emotion actually be
socialized?
So let me give you a few examples.
The first example is through gender stereotypes.
What do I mean by this?
So there was a study done that looked at infants who were being startled.
So you might remember from our earlier lectures on methods to elicit emotion.
The startle response is where you just present a loud noise blast and look at
how different people respond,
kind of getting startled and how much they get startled.
So they studied infants,
uh,
from a very young age and looked at how they responded to being startled and
they videotaped the infants and then showed these videos back to parents who
were asked to rate the emotions of these poor little infants being startled by a
loud noise blast.
What's really interesting here was not so much how the infants actually
deferred,
but how the parents rated the emotions of these infants.
So young infant girls were rated as more fearful.
Um,
and young infant boys,
we're actually rated as more angry and determined.
So,
and this was just them being told what gender the infant was drastically shaped
the way parents perceive the emotions of these infants in response to the same
startled queue.
We also see many gender stereotypes,
you know,
not only in books like men are from Mars,
women are from Venus,
but also from different,
you know,
random romantic comedies out there such as the swan.
I'm the ugly truth,
right?
So we see these depicted in our readings and in the media as well.
Okay.
Example too,
of how emotions may be socialized.
So there's a study here that actually looks at the early conversations that
occur between young children and their parents here.
This is really interesting.
So,
um,
there was a study that looked at conversations between moms and their children's
about important emotional events.
And what they actually found is that mothers really talk quite differently to
their sons and their daughters.
So with their sons,
um,
mothers often talk about anger and that seems to be the primary emotion that
gets discussed with young boys.
By contrast,
the way moms talk with their young daughters is quite different.
It's more than just one kind of emotion that's really focused on,
they share this rich emotional vocabulary with young girls talking about a
variety of many different emotions states.
So what we're seeing is from an early age,
girls are socialized to develop this rich emotion vocabulary while boys are
narrowly concentrated just to this one emotion of anger.
The third example are actually from child rearing manuals.
So one of the famous examples is this book,
um,
by Benjamin Spock,
the pocket book of baby and childcare.
And in this particular book,
um,
when it gives parent advice that says for girls,
you really should try to encourage girls to cry and be emotional.
Whereas with boys and doctor Spock's book,
he says you want to encourage anger,
you know,
and sort of out of control behavior,
right?
So you want to encourage them to express these emotions,
um,
and that these emotions are encouraged differentially between girls and boys.
Um,
and so what's really interesting here is not whether this is terrible advice to
be encouraging your children to be,
you know,
uh,
excessively emotional,
but more sort of what are the kinds of emotions that you are focusing on between
girls and boys.
Here we're seeing an emphasis with emotionality and crying with girls.
And again,
with boys,
it's really about this emotion of anger that seems to be discussed and,
and sort of,
um,
you know,
uh,
emphasized in these child rearing manuals.
Okay.
But what does the data actually suggests?
So given the strong socialization differences between young boys and girls,
how might men and women actually then differ in their emotional responses when
you take them into the lab and use some of the same methods or tools of
emotional elicitation that we've talked about earlier in the course?
Do we actually see differences emerge?
And so here,
um,
I just want to acknowledge that a lot of this work was done by,
Mazda Irene Banaji at Harvard University and our own Marion the France here at
Yale University.
Um,
so they have been some of the pioneers behind looking and providing a
comprehensive review of the literature on this topic.
Um,
and when we look at what people have found,
I want to remind ourselves that what we want to do is when looking at emotional
differences between men and women,
we want to keep this same framework that we've talked about from the beginning
of the course.
So looking at emotion as a multi componential response with subjective reports
of internal emotion experience,
looking at outward displays of behavior or expressions in the face as well as
physiological responses both in the autonomic nervous system and at the neural
level in the brain.
So what do we see first with subjective emotion?
Here's what's interesting.
So for subjective emotion differences,
um,
we do see Jen gender differences emerge but only under certain conditions.
And so I've highlighted these here in purple.
So we see gender differences in the self reports of emotion emerge when they're
asked to rate their emotion directly.
So there's just supposed to rate their own emotion state.
You see,
men and women differ.
So men will report,
or sorry,
women will report greater intensity of emotion.
You don't see differences.
However,
when they look at self reports of emotion indirectly.
So ask people to sort of write about a story of an emotional experience and
describe it.
The second row here looks at on this idea of public display.
So when you ask people to report about sort of how they display their emotions,
um,
there's gender differences emerging when you include items such as asking
people,
uh,
you know,
to rate the extent to which they agree with the statement that most people can
tell what I'm feeling.
Um,
you see gender differences emerge here where women more often rate,
uh,
or highly endorsed this item,
but you don't see gender differences emerge when they're reporting about their
own private or internal experience.
Um,
third row here is looking at this interview versus um,
uh,
intra personal,
which it should say here on the right and,
uh,
instead.
So we see gender differences emerge and people report their emotions when
they're around other people,
but you don't see differences emerge when they're talking more interpersonally
or being alone.
And then finally at the bottom,
um,
when you ask people to report how they feel globally,
you do see gender differences emerge.
Um,
but you don't see them emerge when you're reporting really specific or discrete
emotions like happiness or sadness.
So again,
when we think about the subjective of emotion,
there are differences that emerge.
But not always.
So it's really under specific conditions when emotions are being rated directly,
when they're related to reports of public displays of emotion,
when they're referring to interpersonal emotions.
And when emotions are rated globally across these domains,
what you generally see is women reporting greater emotion experience than men.
Okay?
Now,
so what if we look at behavior,
right?
So you can see the woman in the top left showing behavioral display a fear.
What do we generally see?
So we do see that women,
uh,
generally express more behavioral expressions of emotion of men.
And we see this across a variety of measures.
So we see this across EMG,
which is applying electrodes to the face that measure different contractions of
muscles.
And we also see it across,
um,
self reported measures of how much people think they smile.
And also looking at sort of nonverbal gesturing.
Women seem to be more expressive across these measures.
When we look at emotional behavior,
we also see it evident across a variety of different emotional displays as well.
Sadness,
disgust,
fear,
surprise and happiness.
And this is a review that was done by crying.
And Gordon,
as you can see here on the bottom.
So it seems to be the case that women are more emotionally expressive in their
behavior than men.
However,
when we look at the level of physiological responding,
we're not seeing strong evidence suggesting gender differences.
So we don't see robust evidence suggesting differences in neuro responding in
the brain,
looking at things like the Amygdala or the prefrontal cortex that is related to
the cognitive control of emotion.
And we also don't see differences at the level of the autonomic nervous system.
So looking at skin conductance,
heart rate,
cardiac vagal tone,
we do not see robust physiological differences between men and women and
response to emotionally evocative stimuli.
So to summarize these differences,
what we're seeing is when we look at subjective emotion,
women generally report more emotion than men,
but only in certain contexts.
Um,
when it comes to behavior,
women are generally more expressive than men,
but when it comes to the physiological responding,
we see few,
if,
if no biological differences that seem to emerge whatsoever.
Um,
the caveat here to keep in mind that,
that these are general tendencies between men and women across large groups.
So there's lots of room here for individual variation and these are just kind of
general broad strokes of,
of men and women,
uh,
and how they differ in their emotions.
Okay.
So we've talked a bit about today the socialization of emotion and how it really
seems to be the case that even from a young age,
men and women are socialized to experience different emotions and to express
them at higher degrees or intensities.
So even young girls are taught to think and talk more about their emotions and
are more encouraged to express their emotions.
Then young boys,
we've also reviewed experimental findings where we see that women sometimes
report more emotion than men.
Under certain contexts they express more emotion.
Um,
but we don't see any sort of more biological or physiological differences in
emotion.
So what I want to turn now to our is our takeaway questions that summarize the
main,
kind of take home points from what we've reviewed today.
Okay.
So the first question asks,
what are the key pieces of evidence for the socialization of emotion?
What is the evidence that suggest that socialization of emotion actually occurs?
Second,
what are the different domains or components of gender differences that seem to
emerge an emotional responding?
So when you look at subjective behavioral and physiological domains,
where are the gender differences actually occurring in emotion responsivity?
And then finally,
um,
what are the domains of gender similarities where there seemed to be no
differences in emotional responding across,
again,
these three domains,
subjective,
behavioral,
and physiological.
And so now we will move to our expert interview.
Um,
and for our experts and emotion interview.
Uh,
we have the honor speaking with Dr Marion,
the France,
to consider the question of whether men and women emotionally differ.
So doctor the France is a professor of psychology and of women in gender studies
at Yale University where she teaches courses in social psychology and gender
psychology,
as well as nonverbal communication.
So her research focuses on how emotion and power are transmitted in these subtle
emotional communication cues.
Some of her recent work has focused,
in particular on the human smile examining questions such as,
why do when men smile less than women?
Why do women smile when being sexually harassed?
And to whom do babies show a coy smile?
Um,
this work has received widespread attention and various media outlets,
including NPR,
BBC,
NBC,
The New York Times,
among many others.
So I will now turn to an interview with my local Yo colleague,
uh,
Dr Marion La France.
Okay.
As part of our experts in emotion series.
Thanks for a great course.
Yeah.